growing up my sister Sansa loved stories
with princesses and knights but I always
wanted to be scared and my turn came I
would ask old nan to tell us of magic
monsters long ago and the world was new
the children of the forest sang the song
of the earth and the earth listened
magic was strong in those days and the
children could commune with all the
beasts of the forest streams and they're
the greatest of them could even leave
their bodies to hunt and swim and fly in
the skins of animals they were the first
walks then the first men came with fire
and sword they burned the way woods and
cut down the children and holding on
dark magic the children raised the see
shattered the land bridge that the first
men had crossed into the door and that
failed the children brought down the
hammer of waters upon the neck flooding
and transforming it into the bog it is
today after peace came the two races
shared the land and the children's gods
for thousands of years now comes the
good part
nobody knows how or why but the magic of
the children began to emerge in men
maybe one child in a thousand would be
born a warg fewer still would be born
with the sight old man would not speak
of it maester Luwin never believed in it
but with it the children could know of
events far away and even though still to
come
some say the site was the children's
most powerful and terrible secret and
helped turn the tide during the long
night magic has since fled our world
among the small folk any child suspected
of being a war will be left out to die
beyond the wall though a careless hunter
might still find his prey his claws and
teeth the man's mind to guide them for
the wildlings have a different idea of
monsters but even wildlings keep their
distance from a warg because and here
all nan would lean in close and whisper
how can you tell if the man is wearing
the beast or the Beast is wearing the
man now
old nan has no more tales and maester
Luwin will never scoff again that's fine
I don't like scary stories anymore
because I'm in one